I'm flip Phillips from Skidmore College
soon-to-be Rochester Institute of
Technology I am talking about classroom
projects that we have done in with
Mathematica the title of the talk is
apples and oranges computational
thinking with colorimetry we're gonna
look a little bit at how we develop some
project-based courses where we combine
hardware data acquisition a little bit
of the device toolkits some machine
learning of the resultant data and the
student experience
so hi I I'm flip Phillips
I am from Skidmore with the replacement
rule of going to Rochester Institute of
Technology I'm going to talk a little
bit today about the how we do a
computational thinking
esque kind of class and it's a
project-based class and I'll kind of
walk you through it okay there we go so
it turns out so we've been offering a
course like this since the late 90s and
it turns out a lot of people you know
it's like a psychology department
you know computation all these other
things I I am surprised
to notice that skip which is the Society
for computers insight has been around
since 1971 the people who do this kind
of thing we have a whole journal related
to this BRM and it's a high-impact
journal and it's a research methods
journal over the years it turns out that
psych and neuro have been adopters of
computation for a lot of different
reasons stimulus presentation obviously
analysis and things like that a lot of
computational modeling but it so like it
turns out hold on here the over the
years we've taught this class with
either specialized software of some kind
so we've used like RSVP is a stimulus
presentation system some neural network
software we've used our own experimental
language that has that wonderful self
referential yield stands for real
experimental language we were talking
about that we've done some world
building things there's a system called
psycho Pi that we've used we've done a
lot of robotic base stuff as well we've
used Python recently we're using more
recently we're using Mathematica and we
the class the goal of the class isn't so
much to teach people about what it means
to program as much as it is for teaching
people about stimulus generation
teaching people about you know tools for
analysis and tools for control my main
background is in what's called
psychophysics those of you who are
physicists may now you know tut-tut that
the idea but the it turns out that and
those of you who are perceptual
neuroscientists may now cheer
wholeheartedly in that it turns out that
and feckner here who was both a
philosopher and a physicist made this
observation that and he sometimes by the
way seen as the father of modern
Experimental Psychology and he made this
observation that the physical world is
not perceived in a uniform or even
consistent way so things you measure in
the physical world people's ability to
detect differences in weights or
differences in brightness loudness color
things that are easy to measure
physically perceptually doubling the
weight of something does not double it's
a phenomenological experience of weight
doubling the number of photons coming
out of there doesn't double the amount
of light so feckner was very big on this
whole idea of physics exists in the
world but the way the brain interprets
it is not always consistent with that
this is the most classic example of this
I can ever show people this is Roger
Shepard from Stanford this these two
tables and again I'm gonna I'll show you
this and you still won't believe me
those two tables have exactly the same
shape of a table top and I realized
later and I didn't this it kills me from
the last talk I should have used flip
view for this just as no no I should
yeah anyway yeah thanks thanks but those
tables are exactly the same size exactly
the same shape right and so it and now
and again physically we go you go
measure them they're exactly the same
but when you look at it like that it's
it's totally inconsistent now there
this is some people call these things in
allusion most of these things are
basically misperceptions and I wouldn't
even call misperceptions they're correct
perceptions it's just that you don't do
the right stuff in your head when it
comes to measuring angles and measuring
distances the fact that this is embedded
in 3d you know makes a big pretty big
deal about this so in this class we've
had it's been a project-based class like
I talked about before and these are just
some of the projects that I pulled off
of the thing some of the students were
upset that the face recognition
algorithms do not recognize cartoon
faces
although orden and now the image
identify recognizes a very small set of
a taxonomy of certain faces so one group
wrote a cartoon face recognition system
which I thought was beautiful well
before we had this ability to do things
with video like we have now we've done a
lot of rap behavior monitoring so we
wrote our own software for using ffmpeg
and and reading things in and out of the
language had a student write a whole
series of genetic algorithms for a
creature that could sense its world and
basically evolve in its world lots of
visual system simulation of other
animals so animals that have 3 4 5 some
dozen different photoreceptors
simulating kind of what that is modeling
prosopagnosia so face blindness so it's
always kind of ironic you've got these
face detection algorithms but then if
you are if you there are certain
neurological problems that cause you not
to be able to see faces so they went
back in took a face recognition
algorithm blurred the faces in
systematic ways and then retrained the
algorithm and it turns out that just
like with people that it does anybody
prosopagnosia does this mean things to
most of it yeah anybody have it in here
it's a it's some somewhat weirdly common
can always use it to get out of a you
know I do you and one of the ways that
the
that people with faith hope is they use
things like hair or they use things like
you know the fact that he always wears
white shirts or the tone of voice and
things like that and when they program
they used a they used a classic image
recognition face recognition network and
they found out that whenever they fed it
test things if it was wearing similar
clothing to the person in the picture it
would identify it as the person in the
picture so or different hair so blonde
all blonde haired people this is Seeley
here everyone fed into the algorithm
that had blonde hair was ceiling so I
thought that was kind of a fun thing
I've had other students in this class
from different departments we had some
political science students who were
modeling things and they were trying to
predict they wrote this huge network for
predicting vote voter behavior this was
my favorite a business student a
computer science student and I can't
remember the third what he was I think
he was an English major wrote a
simulating asteroid impacts and whether
it would eliminate the population of the
earth so it's not all psych modeling so
yeah so the the spring 2000 project I
had a smaller class than I usually did
because of scheduling conflict and so he
decided to do one main project together
yes sir
yes but I'm gonna talk now a little bit
about what the idea was that I'm gonna
just give you an example of a longer
term that wasn't just one thing it was
the whole class that was the end result
no that's what I'm going yeah that's the
whole point so I'm gonna talk about this
project so the project was again broad
familiarity with computation so
programming and the whole idea that
programming is not a you know this is
this from a syllabus you know you don't
learn how to program and and it's not
even worth thinking about it that way
secondarily the idea of data you know
what what does it mean what how do we
use it in our
field and one of the things the students
were interested in in this particular
incarnation of the class was what they
wanted use some hardware and so we
created this project and this is
actually the this is the kind of the I
don't know spec sheet for this thing but
they wanted to create a system that
could learn to identify and recognize
different types of fruit
it started out because of course like
all good college students you know it's
like well we got some things we want to
measure and one of the students had I
they stole but they took a bunch of
fruit from the dining hall had a
backpack full basically a fruit we
dumped it out on the table and we
started measuring it so the idea was
that we were gonna collect the data
do a little bit of hardware do a little
bit of machine learning that was another
thing they requested and then we were
gonna try to deploy this thing so how do
we do this and so the to the
computational thinking part here the
idea and and this is I've been and not
just because for the ironic reasons I've
never been a big flipped class person
and for those of you are not know what
that is in general the idea is you give
people work upfront to do we used to
call it homework but then instead of
doing that work as just adjunct to the
stuff you're supposed to learn you do
the work because and then you come in
and actually apply the work in class
that's a flipped classrooms are far more
detailed than that but we basically used
the GI WL chapters then we use Jesse's
streaming notebook stuff this semester
thank you again yeah oh yeah oh yes yes
indeed yes sorry because the the way we
usually do this class is we pass around
we're in a room like this and we patent
here's one of the students who have
stolen the the fruit and we pass around
a video cable you know people kind of
patch in and then you display it back
here on the board but so this time
around though the the
we used the shared notebooks and then we
also would record my interaction so
people the idea the flipped classroom is
you're having trouble with this we all
work on this together that's where the
shared notebook stuff comes in handy all
right student X says I'm having trouble
with this part you just deploy that to
everybody in the classroom everybody
works on it everybody can kind of share
the results back and forth but then we
use ScreenFlow and then Skidmore uses
Ensemble to distribute things so we had
basically video of you know feeds of the
classes that students could go back and
watch later and finally because I come
from a design school under grab we used
we use kind of a we use the Charette
system which is the way you do design
review in you know like architectural
design or product design which involves
it's a group critique kind of thing so
the way we started off was basically
with the idea of a photometer photometer
measures the number of photons the
radiant flux over a certain servers over
certain amount of time in and there's an
SI unit and we could probably get a full
set of detail on this but the idea was
we used an Arduino taught them some very
basic electronics had them go out and
learn a little bit about what a voltage
divider was things like that and then we
also used commercial measurement
equipment so we had to write an external
system for getting the data from that in
as well that that I just have in my lab
already and the idea and here's you know
some data from one of these things was
to literally try to calibrate the a
photocell against the against the actual
amount of light coming in so the ID and
then we did a similar set of things
where we then did the psychological part
of it where we had people estimate the
magnitude of the brightness of the light
and then compared it to this also so the
the idea of in this whole lesson this
part of this lesson was to get them to
think about the idea of a just you know
getting information into the computer
and then calibrating that information
against some kind of truth or some kind
of ground truth or something along those
lines again there's a billion different
ways to do that as well but at least we
could do it here and then to use that to
perform experiments downstream they
built with that they built a kind of a a
faux color immature from there but then
we built we went ahead and used and
super talk just a minute ago they he
talked about one of these types of
things we actually used a real six
channel spectrophotometer chip that
instead of giving you X Y Z or you know
location and color space actually gives
you the magnitude at six different bands
of visible electromagnetic radiation we
used the Arduino to and and we basically
this was a good chance for them to learn
how to do procedural coding at a very
basic level so they wrote a little
Arduino code and again they took
measurements they then took those
measurements and computed responses and
things like this so the idea was from
again from the physical world gonna
gather that data we're gonna then go in
and estimate spectra of different types
of fruit and the whole idea and well
maybe we can use that right there or
some vector derived from this as a way
to identify different types of fruit
with our little scanner it turns out
though that if you do that and with a
pretty good amount of data you end up
with not very good classification those
who'd all be bananas down there at the
bottom and you can see it's only about
sixty percent solid so we had some other
things to look at one of which was some
friends of mine at Giessen had built
this gigantic database of fruits and
vegetables they used a camera that has
four hundred bands of it so it's a
hyperspectral camera it's got four
hundred bands at one nanometer
resolution so they're able to just
sample the in the bejesus out of these
fruits inside and outside it turns out
that the good news for that is that
here in an L and M cones these are your
what we would think of as green and red
cones in the visual system the Ellen M
cones there there's a nice way of
figuring out of classifying a fruit
based on the relative amount of
excitation of that particular set of
cells in your retina and again
neuroscience class right ideas look at
this see what's going on that's a good
news
the bad news is that that's all 42 fruit
that's the spectra of all 42 fruit and
trying to discriminate fruit based on
their spectra alone because you'll
notice it's like a literal traffic jam
when you get out here to the right it's
really really hard taking a single scan
of a single fruit and trying to get
figure out what it is based on the its
actual spectral content it just it
doesn't work very well so the students
built an auto encoder so that some
students wanted to do some machine
learning they taught the other students
what they had known a little bit about
this basic idea of taking a piece of six
channel data mapping it to these 400
channel data measurements and then you
know testing they they did this is all
from their notebook where they tested
the network against itself and then they
created this association between the six
channel data that we had and they were
able to get the thing to literally from
a piece of six channel data where you
saw before banana apple banana apple
banana they were able to get almost a
hundred percent reliability by using the
hyper spectral data as their kind of as
the space that they were projecting the
little six channel measurements into so
and there's a little machine they built
to do it complete with fruit related
buttons on the thing it was 98 percent
accuracy
we couldn't find blue fruit but even
though George Carlin was not available
no blueberries are not blue so yeah
there's a whole bit on this so the
original idea what they wanted to do and
we didn't have time the dotted lines are
what they originally
wanted to do is they wanted to build and
and we even have we've got the little
case they we wanted the students to be
able to digitize fruit in the dining
hall use the Wi-Fi because there's
several of these Arduino is that have
Wi-Fi so we'd use the the the photometry
chip use Wi-Fi to send it up to a data
drop and then basically use that to
build the spectrum database that we
would then later on used to build the
auto encoder and we just rant we
basically ran out of time and since Suba
is not here the we had trouble with
there was some implementation details
with the with the microcontroller kit
that allowed the Wi-Fi kind of setup and
the data drop setup wasn't working but
still the whole idea was that you know
we were able to measure bananas and
predict bananas with a reasonable amount
of reliability so real quickly then it
was basically a 15 week class for upper
level neuroscience so if when I and
again when I say computational thinking
a lot of you and and I do not dispute
this at all I would rat if I'm gonna
teach a true computational thinking
class I'd like to teach it to freshmen
and it would be much more removed from
it would be a little more remove than
this but this is an upper division class
that is optional and the goal is to make
the students aware that there are
techniques methods you know that we use
in our field in different laboratory
settings that and you know that are
basically computationally based we build
a simple spectrophotometer a photometer
they learned how to do really basic
Arduino and electronic things and and at
least we're exposed to procedural
programming then they use Mathematica
and they were able to build a simple
classify these to classify function they
did some machine learning and they did
basically an end to end you know
acquisition to prediction kind of a
thing the thing that's important and
again this is you know kind of goes
without saying didn't teach them how to
be programmers
didn't teach them how to be engineers
didn't teach them to be makers either
this is kind of a big fad especially
where I am it's like everyone has to be
a maker it's like know that making is
and again nothing against being makers
but that's part of it it's a creative
process that feeds into this but doesn't
it doesn't necessarily define this the
goal is we got to solve a problem I need
to acquire data about where a rat is in
a open field maze I got to figure out
whether the rat is posing in a
particular position what do I do
so it did teach them to you know think I
would claim and more importantly it
taught them how to go after the
documentation in Mathematica which again
I continue to think is is wonderful
taught them how to collaborate and and
you know kind of solve these types of
problems
my favorite anecdote from this is with
respect to the manuals and I don't know
if any of you you know if you teach
students the one of these you notice is
that they'll go to Google for everything
and the beautiful whoever's in charge of
this at Wolfram whoever has done the SEO
pretty much if you google Mathematica
list plot it takes you to Wolfram's page
and so therefore they're reading the and
I just love the confusion on their face
they're reading the Wolfram
documentation in you know Safari or
whatever and then you show them that
it's built in to the thing and they
don't need to go there but they would
still rather took over and type Google
and go to this page right and so
thankfully the same documentation is out
there as his in here but you know so
like I said again not at not a not a
computational thinking class at its base
to get to your point but a way of
thinking about it within the domain of
psycho neural so that's all I got thank
you for your attention
you